let's start with some more economic news
and financial news yesterday we started
the show digging into some
uh more meaty economics and finance type
stories people seem to like it
so let's do it again we now have more
detail
about the proposed joe biden tax plan
now you might remember
that during a number of white house
press briefings
um jen saki the white house press
secretary
would repeat this line nobody making
under four hundred thousand dollars a
year
would pay any more under joe biden and
gensake was rightly confronted with the
question
is that four hundred thousand individual
or is that four hundred thousand
for a couple uh because typically there
are two different
sort of cutoffs for individuals versus
couples and gensake would weirdly say
it's for both which didn't make any
sense and at the time i called it out
and some of you got mad and said david
sir no no
it didn't make any sense now we have
more visibility
into what the actual policy is going to
be and so let's dig into it there's a
new report from cnbc
joe biden's proposed 39.6
top tax rate would apply at these income
levels now as a reminder what we're
talking about here is something really
uncontroversial just just so you
remember
we're talking about going back from 37
to 39.6
all of this debate about raising taxes
on the rich
what we're talking about is just going
back to a rate we previously had for top
earners which was 39.6 instead of
instead of 37
that's all we're talking about here uh
the rate would
affect this is the key part the rate
would affect
single individuals with a taxable income
of more than 452
700 a year and married couples filing
jointly
with income over five hundred and nine
thousand three hundred dollars according
to a budget proposal issued
friday also important to remember
the top rate is slated to increase to
39.6 percent
after 2025 even if congress doesn't pass
biden's proposal
so understand you know when we talk
about
truly progressive economic policy
and we look at some of the things they
have in northern europe
i have friends in the netherlands who
are are working
uh there and have told me about the the
tax structure
there we are here talking about
a disagreement between republicans and
democrats
most around the edges where we're saying
once you get to 450 000 a year in income
on everything you earn beyond that
because remember it's a marginal
tax marginal tax system should you pay
37
or 39.6 percent so let me give you an
example of how
relatively little of an impact this has
on people who would actually
pay it okay remember that because it's
marginal
up to 450 to 700 you pay what people
earning less than that pay
once you get to 452 700
a year you start paying 39.6 instead of
37. so imagine someone making one
million dollars a year
okay if you make a million dollars a
year
if on everything above 452
000 you go from paying 37
to 39.6 that's an extra 2.6 percentage
points
on that difference your total tax
from this big tax increase is
an increase of 10 900 for the year now i
have
you know i'm a big personal finance guy
maybe i'm a better saver or budgeter
than other people
if you're making a million dollars a
year gross
and ten thousand nine hundred dollars a
year in extra taxes
changes your lifestyle you're doing
something wrong you're not budgeting
correctly
you're not managing your finances
correctly okay when we talk about
uh paying an extra 2.6 percent on
the 547 thousand dollars that would be
subject to that top tax rate if that
materially changes your lifestyle in any
way
you are terrible with money and i'll be
honest you probably don't make a million
dollars a year to begin with
unless you you know are getting that
through some kind of inheritance or
whatever right
but if if you're like an entrepreneur
making a million dollars a year
you probably are good enough with your
money that you won't even notice
this extra ten thousand nine hundred
dollars a year in taxes that's under an
extra thousand dollars a month for
someone making a million bucks a year
so that is what we're talking about and
of course the reaction from many people
to this is going to be
why aren't we talking about a higher uh
rate for people making even more what
about as i've proposed
before many times don't we need a higher
bracket where okay it goes to 39.6 when
you get to 452 000 but
maybe at 1 million dollars a year in
income it goes to 42
maybe at 2 million a year in income it
goes to
46 these are the types of proposals that
have been outlined by some of the most
progressive members of congress
and we're like just barely even touching
the edges here
so this is what the debate is about and
importantly as the article reminds us
the trump tax cuts of 2017
which dropped that rate from 39.6 to 37
they automatically expire in 2025 if
congress does nothing
okay so i know we have a presidential
election in 2024
it may be consequential in many ways one
of those ways would be what does it do
to that top tax rate but
what we're talking about here it's
almost laughable right
like the debate right now is
should the rate for those making over
450k a year
go to from 37 now
and by now i mean like you know this
year next year
or should it not happen until 2025.
that's the big debate and i will never
understand
although people like jonathan height
have explained it to me i still don't
totally get it
why do people who make forty thousand
dollars a year care about this
the the you you've got people who make
thirty thousand forty thousand fifty
sixty seventy thousand dollars a year
even ninety or a hundred thousand
dollars a year going
crazy about how joe biden wants to
increase your taxes we're talking about
2.6 percentage points on people making
nearly half a million dollars a year or
more
and the outrage from these folks i don't
get now
somebody like jonathan height would say
what's going on here is it's not about
whether
joe the plumber making 400 i'm sorry
making 40 000
a year is actually going to pay more
personally
it's about whether he identified he or
she but i'm we're talking about joe the
plumber imaginary here
it's about whether joe deplo the plumber
joe diploma
joe the plumber believes that
this is a tax change that is on his team
or it's for someone else's team and we
saw it in 2010 with the tea party
the tea party uh a bunch of people
making very little money who were very
proudly and loudly
against tax increases for the very very
rich so
that's the situation we now have the
exact numbers from the joe biden
proposal and administration and um it
is shocking to me how many people don't
even understand that we have a marginal
tax system like i've met lawyers
who think that if the tax top tax rate
is 39.6 percent
if you make a million bucks a year you
pay 39.6
on all of your income when the reality
is you pay that only on the income
above that top tax threshold
disturbing that so many people seem not
to understand this but these are the
numbers we now have them
and we'll see what the reaction is from
the right okay
from the standpoint of jobs and
unemployment things are continuing to
improve
and i am further reassured that what i
uh told you yesterday would happen by
september october november is going to
happen
all of these right-wingers as i told you
yesterday are
very very worried about how it's more
profitable
to be on unemployment than to go back
and work
jobs at restaurants and retail stores
and other places that are now reopening
as we exit the pandemic
my position on this has been the
enhanced unemployment
has been one of the most effective
pieces
of covet stimulus sure anecdotally there
are
some people who are making roughly the
same or maybe even a little bit more
with that enhanced unemployment and
maybe they're choosing not to go back to
work for the time being but
that unemployment is going to end and
they're going to have no choice but to
go back to work
we're starting to see this increasingly
happen and we now have a new report from
yahoo finance based on new department of
labor data
initial filings last week we just we
learned today
on thursday we get the numbers for the
previous week new jobless claims
have dropped below 400 000
for the first time since march of 2020.
this is a fifth consecutive week with a
new low
this is now a 14-month low
fewer and fewer americans are becoming
newly unemployed
initial jobless claims came in at 385
000 just below the expected 387
thousand uh continuing claims
are at 3.7 million
slightly higher than the 3.6
million that were expected again this is
the first time
since the start of the pandemic where
new jobless claims have dropped below
400
000 and this is now starting to get
close to the pre-pandemic weekly rate
this is an important thing to understand
this is not a political statement this
is just what it is
in a good normal economy you still have
new unemployment claims every week and
you know we've talked before about at
what point does the risk of going out in
the world get back to the baseline level
because it was never
zero even before kovid you could go out
and catch the flu
you could catch a stomach bug you could
get run over by a bus etc
so it's about going back to the baseline
we were seeing
even in the great economy that i agree
was was in place during the trump
administration
before the pandemic hit great in many
ways and yet we still had stagnant wages
and other issues
you still saw 200 something new uh 200
something thousand
new unemployment claims every week so
when you look at that number 385
it's almost back down to the pre
pandemic
level this is further evidence
that as people's unemployment benefits
uh
continue start to and continue to run
out
um and as more and more aspects of the
economy
are reopened as more and more people's
kids go back to school
so that parents who don't have child
care can actually get back to work
we are going to see the issue that the
right claims is a big issue of people
just hanging out at home
raking in the dough on unemployment it's
going to resolve itself the unemployment
is going to end the enhanced
unemployment ends in september
people state unemployment will
ultimately run out even with the various
extensions that different states provide
and people are going to have to go back
to work now there's going to be a real
question here
about whether we see stronger lobbying
efforts
uh for better wages and you know the the
economy is a complicated thing when we
say
what about a 15 minimum wage as i said
before there are parts of the country
where cost of living is so high that a
15
minimum wage is too low that's just the
reality there are other parts of the
country
where the cost of living is very very
low and
going to a 15 minimum wage immediately
actually could be a significant shock to
the economy particularly states
that still have the federal minimum wage
as the prevailing minimum wage and so
these are really regionalized issues
much the same way
depending on which state you live in and
depending on what the cost of living is
and depending on what
the wages are that are being paid there
there are jobs that as a result of all
of this are probably going to have to
start paying people more in order to get
people to come back to work
part of that is going to be because of
some large businesses everything from
you know amazon bank of america has made
an announcement a
similar announcement have upped the
minimum wage that they are going to pay
this is going to lead to some businesses
having to pay more in order to attract
people
and that's okay now if you said they're
going to have to pay 100 bucks an hour
that's a straw man red herring that's
not an equilibrium minimum wage it's not
adjusted to cost of living it's not
adjusted to anything that makes sense
it's a straw man from the right
they love to say hey listen people
having more money is better
make the minimum wage 100 bucks an hour
make it a thousand bucks an hour
nobody's calling for that that's a
serious person because that's not an
equilibrium wage tied to
inflation productivity cost of living or
anything else
that being said remember that when
people
make more money that is a cost to the
employer
but then people in the community have
more money
to go and spend at that business imagine
a hardware store for example
this is often an example that's given
hardware store all of a sudden has a
higher wage they have to pay either
because of the minimum wage has gone up
or because
they need to raise wages to attract
workers they go from eight bucks an hour
to 12 bucks an hour uh oh their payroll
costs have just gone up that's terrible
right that'll kill their business
well hold on a second if the entire
region now sees
a 12 minimum wage instead of eight you
now have all sorts of people
who because they are earning more money
they're going to go to the hardware
store and say hey you know what i'm
going to get a new vacuum
or i'm going to get what i need to
refinish my floors or i'm going to
finish my basement or whatever the case
may be
and even though the hardware store now
has to pay more out in wages
they have all of these customers that
now have money to go and spend and do
projects so
revenue goes up as well this analysis
only works
within what we would consider an
equilibrium wage
it's really important to understand that
so
that's the latest in terms of
unemployment claims this is going to be
resolved
mostly on its own some businesses are
going to have to start paying more
there's no question about that because
they have been paying
sub market wages for a really long time
uh
and that is going to be a problem for
them for the most part this issue is
going to resolve itself i'm already
seeing it happen
in these numbers let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at d
pacman we've got a really great show for
you today
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
lest we forget i do want to mention that
our program
is an independent non-corporate media
program we don't have
big corporate funders dumping money on
us
or a money tree i have many things in my
backyard garden but no money tree at
least that i've been able to figure out
yet
we depend primarily on memberships from
folks like you who just go to
joinpakman.com
and sign up it's quick it's easy and
until the end of the week you can use
the coupon code memorial21 this was the
big memorial day special still available
through the end of the week
memorial 21 gets you a beautiful
discount
uh only 19 bucks for an entire one-year
membership can you believe my
lawyers and accountants are saying don't
do it david the staff is coming to me
saying
sir i don't really make them call me sir
will we be able to earn our salary if
the memberships are so
cheap everybody relax it's a beautiful
discount 19 bucks for the year if you
use the code
memorial21 at joinpakman.com
all right let's get to uh some notable
discussions from the david pakman show
subreddit
um you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit and now 31 000
of you are subscribed for free
to the subreddit um a user named
plenitude opulence posted a video of
radical republican congressman matt
gates
having a beverage thrown at him in
pensacola
florida now my position on this stuff
has always been the same
i'm against it i'm against it it is it i
i know that this guy
is disgusting i know that this guy is
depraved i know that this guy represents
so much of what is wrong with the united
states at this point of time at this
time
i'm not denying that he's horrible uh if
he has committed crimes he should be
charged and he's currently under
investigation
he should be voted out etc etc
uh but throwing drinks at people you
know it's just it's beneath us
and i am against it so i know that the
video went viral and people are laughing
and it's all a big party
uh i i think that this is um i'm i'm not
against
using incendiary language when it's
appropriate
or engaging in hyperbole for a fact or
whatever but throwing drinks at people
i am against it i am very much against
it and very much the same
um user william mcadoo or
mccadu posted to the subreddit
this story of this anti-mask
anti-vaccine
police officer 33 year old police
officer
who has died of covid19 you know when i
see this
there are some people who see this stuff
and they gloat and they say this guy
deserved it
and hahaha he denied that you need
vaccines he was a kova deny or was
against masks
and uh he now he's dead i take no
pleasure in that i really don't and as
i've said before it's something about me
constitutionally even when rush limbaugh
someone as disgusting as rush limbaugh
who made so many people's lives a living
hell by furthering
uh homophobia and xenophobia and all of
this stuff
i take no pleasure in seeing that rush
limbaugh got lung cancer
i take no pleasure in the fact that
people who loved him and
there were people i guess who did um
were are now
or did suffer i take no pleasure in that
and i take no pleasure in the fact that
this 33 year old police officer despite
being a kova denier
uh died uh i don't know i just i just
can't do it and i know some people are
taking pleasure in it but that
is not for me for me it's more about
uh everybody could be at risk and
we should get vaccinated because you
might be one of those young people that
gets it and dies why take the chance and
the
the covid19 vaccine is so effective that
it makes the chance of you dying from
covid
at any age group dramatically lower
and so go and get vaccinated that's the
lesson the lesson is not haha
somebody died it's go and get yourself
vaccinated
lastly on the subreddit user b scolo
posted if and it's a big if
it's proven that the coronavirus
did leak from the wuhan institute of
virology
for which there is no public evidence at
this time hypothetically
what would the international reaction
and response be
china is arguably a superpower on the
same
footing with the usa eu etc
what consequences would they actually
face also in this hypothetical scenario
does war with china become a serious
platform idea for the 2024 republican
presidential nomination
edit because i say i guess i should say
it i do not believe the virus leak from
the lab i suspect
the overwhelmingly likely scenario is it
jumped from an animal in the wild
yeah uh so you know what's really funny
about this
republicans um love to say
joe biden is gonna get us into all these
different wars and they like to say joe
biden is
soft on china and the reality is
i don't think joe biden's going to get
us into any wars
and joe biden has been reasonable on
china in my estimation
if indeed there was the discovery and i
mean listen when we say if
china obviously lied about cases early
they seem to be lying about deaths
there's no question in my mind china did
tell lies about what was going on with
the pandemic that's separate from the
lab leak
hypothesis uh okay um i
do think that if the word war
isn't used it's going to be probably
something else
but if the lab leak hypothesis were to
even be proven partially and i'm not
talking about a bioengineered virus but
just it was being studied and there was
an accident right
for which there was no evidence at this
time very important to say
i think you are going to see the closest
to just straight up the beating of war
drums from republicans
heading into 2024 and it will all be
promised on biden
biden didn't do enough on the one hand
they've been saying biden's going to get
us into all these wars because he's a
warmonger i've seen no evidence of that
on the other hand uh they are going to
be saying biden didn't do enough on
china and
i whether it's trump or whoever it is
that is the republican nominee in 2024
will be alluding to something that will
probably feel very much like a war yeah
i think there's a real probability of
that
join the discussion on the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t okay
let's now talk about what's going on
with what could
maybe be and could have been a real
commission to investigate what happened
on the day of the trump riots january 6
2021. there's a new piece in huffpost
very interesting piece by jennifer
bendery called
the 139 republicans who lied
fueled an insurrection and then voted to
cover it up
she writes last week 35 senate
republicans
killed a bipartisan effort to create an
independent commission to investigate
the january 6th insurrection at the u.s
capitol
arguably the greatest attack on american
democracy
since the civil war it would indeed have
been bipartisan
remember that that's really important
some republicans are saying it would
have been a partisan witch hunt it was
going to be
ten members of the house five democrats
five republicans
five chosen by democrats five chosen by
republicans
the chair of the commission would have
been a democrat and the vice chair would
have been a republican
because democrats control the house
after all and all subpoenas issued
would have had to be signed off on by
both the democratic chair
and the republican vice chair it was
going to be the closest you could have
to a truly bipartisan commission many
republicans saying it was going to be a
partisan witch hunt
um she goes on to write a week earlier
135 175 house republicans
oppose creating the commission too why
would any u.s
senator or member of congress oppose an
independent commission
to investigate what led to a deadly
attack on the u.s capitol one aimed
squarely at undermining american
democracy and the peaceful transfer of
power
the reasons are as cynical as they are
obvious and this is the exact analysis
we gave last week
most of these republicans lied about the
presidential election being stolen from
donald trump
that lie helped motivate a white
supremacist mob of trump supporters
to smash their way into the capital some
with plans to kill house speaker nancy
pelosi vice president mike pence and
others
to stop congress from certifying joe
biden's electoral win
republicans don't want a respected panel
of experts publicly connecting the dots
heading into the 2022 elections this is
an
additional part that's interesting they
also don't want to get on trump's bad
side
by supporting a commission that would
show in detail how his lie
incited an attack on democracy that left
five people dead
hundreds of police officers injured and
countless others traumatized
there are two things going on here
republicans know
these republicans the ones that were
doing the inciting and that voted
against
these republicans know if the
investigation
is done properly they will probably be
in the spotlight as part of the problem
the people doing the commission some of
the people doing the commission
will really be culpable themselves of
what the commission is investigating
that's part one
part two we're going to talk about this
later there is every indication
that yes not only is donald trump
interested in running in 2024
it's probably his nomination to take or
decline
in other words there is every indication
that many
or most republicans still believe and
why wouldn't they it's borne out in the
polls
republicans still accurately believe
that trump is the head of the party
trump will play king maker in 2022 trump
is about to restart rallies trump is
still pushing these audits and trump is
likely to try to run in 2024 if a health
issue keeps him out of it as many of you
write to me and say okay
but that is likely the reality and so
why would you get on trump's bad side by
voting in favor of this because trump
holds grudges and trump is vindictive
and he will remember
one more piece from this article
jennifer bendery writes it gets uglier
their party is counting on people to
keep believing the lie
republican-led state legislatures all
over the country are using the lie to
justify
quickly passing bills to significantly
restrict voting in ways that would
disproportionately
hurt communities of color just this year
state lawmakers have already issued at
least 389 restrictive bills in 49 states
and passed
22 restrictive laws in 14 states
it's no coincidence that the four states
where republicans have filed the most
bills aimed at restricting voting
georgia arizona michigan and
pennsylvania
were some of the closest states in the
2020 presidential election as 538 notes
all four of those states went for biden
and have republican-controlled
legislatures which makes them especially
ripe for new voting restrictions so
three reasons here really why you are
seeing this republican opposition
one the commission would likely find
that
they were part of the problem two they
want to stay in donald trump's good
graces because it seems trump is going
to have power and control in the
republican party for a long period of
time to come at least through the 2022
election if he fails to pick the winners
in 2022
things may change but at least through
2022 and number three
if they can continue putting off
a real investigation into what happened
which would of course
uncover that the election was fine the
election wasn't rigged
joe biden just won they
lose the ability if that is made public
through the commission
to keep justifying these further
restrictions on voting
that they're passing in many states so
democrats
need to move forward with the probe
without any republicans there's a couple
of ways that it could happen
it would then actually be a partisan
commission now i know what you might be
thinking
you know david republicans falsely say
we don't want to participate in this
because it's going to be partisan
and then as a result democrats just move
forward and it is partisan
that is that that is of course what they
are going to claim
but the benefits of doing the commission
by far outweigh
claims from republicans that it's
partisan because they were going to make
those claims anyway
and we do need to see democrats do
something the headlines continue coming
that democrats aren't holding them
accountable and
to a degree it's true now so far they've
been trying to just get the votes to do
it with republicans
it's not clear that that's going to
happen they've got to figure out a move
for a way to move forward on their own
it'll be called partisan either way so
i'd rather the commission be done
in some way shape or form than not let
me know what you think and we're going
to have more on this on the david pakman
show
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
check it out and we'll be back right
after this
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well read about them
you know back in i guess it was 2017
uh late 2016 as this transition into the
trump era began
uh many of us started talking about
creeping authoritarianism
and hyper normalization and how we
really needed to sort of keep our guard
up
about these slow moves attacking press
freedom
and fighting against uh rights
that we believe to be and know to be
integral to what the united states is
sort of founded on and on and on
there were some who said everything's
fine you don't really have to worry
about it but we now are at a point where
historians who are taking a sort of
broader
look at what the last four to five years
of the republican party uh have done and
have represented historians are
increasingly horrified by the republican
party's
very direct march towards
authoritarianism and i want to look at a
couple of articles
uh that that look at exactly this
there's an interesting article by ben
jacobs advice
called the republicans off the rails
march towards authoritarianism
has historians worried um
where uh the article says last week
senate republicans successfully blocked
legislation
to create a bipartisan commission to
investigate the failed push on january
6th
which resulted in five people dead and
over 400 people arrested
senator lisa murkowski of alaska one of
seven senate
republicans to support the measure
expressed her disgust at her colleagues
vote are we going to acknowledge that as
a country that is based on these
principles of democracy that we hold so
dear
and one of those is that we have free
and fair elections and we respect the
results of those elections and allow
for a peaceful transition of power i
kind of want that to endure
beyond just one election cycle and this
is a concern
that is echoed by more and more scholars
who study american history and the rise
of authoritarianism around the globe
while republics are often fragile they
see the united states in a unique
position
as a mature democracy at the point of
fracturing
as harvard political scientist stephen
lewitsky co-author of how democracies
die
put it bluntly i think we are headed for
a crisis
many scholars say that fracturing is
without
historical precedent levitsky's
co-author daniel ziblot
from harvard writes a mainstream
democratic party that small d
democratic party one of the major
parties in a country
going fully off the rails the
radicalization
and increasing authoritarianism of the
republican
party is what is to blame and the book
argues american democracy is
not inherently exceptional the norms
that hold it together
were rendered vulnerable by the rise of
former president donald trump
the underlying assumption when we wrote
the book was that an important even a
dominant faction of the republican party
was committed to the democratic rules of
the game but that
no longer is the case the gop
over the past four years and far more
quickly and far more thoroughly than i
expected
has become a party capable of stealing
an election
willing and potentially able to steal an
election
and i would not have taken this
seriously when we wrote the book
this is how uh the creeping
hyper normalization works you say well
yeah okay i mean they're trying to
suppress the vote
kind of casually and this has been going
on for a while they tried it in
uh 2008 a little bit and they tried it
more in 2012 and then
more in 2016 and then it went completely
crazy in 2020 and they're just gonna try
to keep doing more of it
but each little step we're now at
bamboo fibers during an audit in arizona
six months after the election and much
of the country supports it
more than half of republicans don't
believe joe biden really
won look at how far we've come and as
i've said before
if i had given you the list if on
november
15 2016 before trump was inaugurated i
gave you the list of the things we would
see in 2020.
even i would have hesitated and said a
lot of this just doesn't seem plausible
and yet it happened
there's uh another very interesting
article in common dreams
called our entire democracy is now at
risk because of republican attacks
warn more than 100 scholars this is by
jessica corbett a staff writer at common
dreams
and this also points out that more than
100 scholars of democracy
put out a joint statement of concern
calling on congress to combat ongoing
republican attacks on voting rights
and ensure fair and free future u.s
elections with federal
legislation published online by the
think tank new america
the scholar statement comes as
republican lawmakers nationwide
continue to propose and enact state
level voter suppression
bills so what i think is important here
to to keep in mind is
we don't want to be hyperbolically
fear-mongering
but we have to resist the normalization
these are scholars with a wider view
than many of us who look at
right now and the last two years and the
last four years and the last few
presidents
when you take a view that is the last
hundred years in the united states
and the last hundred years around the
world and that is your area of expertise
as it is for many of these historians
and they say we are starting to see
signs in the united states
of the republican party looking more and
more like these hyper nationalist
authoritarian regimes as they have
become historically around the world we
need to be listening to that
and of course the right is going to say
oh come on david that is just
liberal academics trying to scare us
because they want democrats to win read
their actual work
dig into some of these check out we're
linking to the vice and the common
dreams articles check out the citations
do the work and you will very quickly
see that if
anything we are not ringing the alarm
enough
about this issue we're going to continue
covering this and have more about it
uh but it is a seriously scary thing
that is going on at this point in time
uh this is exactly why oh i wanted to
mention
this is also you know there's a reason
why we have separation of church and
state because
in in history when there is not a
separation between church and state
it often points to the exact type of
authoritarianism
that we are now seeing now much of what
is going on trump you know he claims to
be religious
he's not a religious guy he had the
assistance
of evangelicals and the more religious
nuttery that we saw within the
republican party people like
uh ted cruz and others but when you
don't have separation of church and
state
we've seen really bad things happen when
you don't have
separation of military and state
we've seen really bad things happen and
so
we are seeing this happen in a sort of
different context but i do think it's
important to remember
you know the idea now of the coup that
michael flynn said should happen
and that donald trump is reportedly
saying he'll be back in power by august
i don't think it can happen without help
from the military i don't think it's a
realistic possibility without help from
the military
but it doesn't make it any less
horrifying that there are people openly
talking about it and
um the the that's an important aspect of
this to remember as well
the indicted and since pardoned trump
associate
roger stone is predicting
that donald trump is going to be
indicted that an indictment of donald
trump is coming and this story didn't
get
much attention over the memorial day
weekend but roger stone
appeared with conspiracy theorist alex
jones
and of course he says it's a witch hunt
of course he says it's nonsense of
course he says
these are going to be trumped up
political charges and it's trash but
roger stone
says an indictment of donald trump is
coming take a look at this video
the globalists love symbolism don't they
well i would be shocked if they
did not come forward with a fabricated
indictment
for bank fraud or tax fraud against the
former president
by manhattan district attorney cyrus
vance
of an elected democrat the son of cyrus
van senior
the worst secretary of state in american
history the man who botched
the iranian hostage crisis under jimmy
carter by the way
cy vance is not exactly a non-corrupt
politician himself
okay so roger stone starts carrying on
there but the big
point is stones saying he'd be shocked
if there
isn't some indictment of donald trump
we previously reported that the grand
jury is being convened
they are looking at evidence they will
decide on charges so this is real in
that sense but trump is lawyered up
presumably has
top lawyers already or almost ready to
represent him
if indeed this were to happen and i
continue to believe
that donald trump's real level of
risk is quite low of ending up in prison
tiny tiny tiny as i've said before but
what about the trump children not baron
and tiffany
but the ones involved in trump's
businesses donald trump jr eric trump
ivanka trump
they are now being advised to lawyer up
personally
because even though any charges if they
ever come will likely be related to
trump organization activity
the trump organization legal team really
represents the interests of the
organization so here is
frank figluzzi former assistant director
for counterintelligence at the fbi
explaining this to msnbc
but nicole as we're talking about
witnesses we might as well go ahead
and talk about kind of those big big
witnesses which is are we going to see
this grand jury
um a subpoena or or are we going to see
subpoenas to testify before this grand
jury for people like
eric don jr and ivanka
and if so are they going to plead the
fifth amendment
against self-incrimination
well you mean you raised that i mean i
remember when the new york times
big investigation into the trump taxes
came out and all that liability
that he had and you were part of our
coverage um
about the national security implications
of that right that he was in so much
debt
if the new york times learned that
certainly foreign government could have
but one of the
one of the line items were big transfers
to ivanka trump
would you guess that they all have
lawyered up in terms of criminal defense
attorneys
i wrote a column about that and so they
they better have to individually
lawyered up
yeah they they have had to have lawyered
up because they may have already made
the mistake
of casually speaking to the organization
attorneys and the organization's
auditors about you know what they knew
and what their role was
big mistake if they'd done that because
the organization doesn't represent them
the organization's lawyers mission is to
preserve the organization
not the individual executives and
officers it becomes every man
or woman for themselves and in this case
the men
and the women happen to be family so
this has
every possibility of escalating
dramatically
uh and one more thing from roger stone
here to get back to him roger stone
predicts
that the timing of these indictments uh
will be
around when the so-called audit in
arizona wraps up
this was mixed between ranting about
other things of course
the damn loan well let's be let's be
very clear in other words as you said it
earlier you show the man i'll show you
the crime
they're allowed to root through this
man's business record
of 40 years in which he built a real
estate empire second to none
combing for a crime they have no
evidence of a crime they have no
probable cause
it is disgraceful but i do think it is
going to happen and
don't be surprised if the announcement
comes at the exact time
that we learn the truth about maricopa
county arizona
don't be surprised because i see that
coming so that ominous timing
predicted by roger stone is this just
nonsense
or does roger stone actually know
something or is he just guessing
after all roger stone told me during our
interview that he would never be
indicted by the fbi
and he was indicted by the fbi so maybe
roger stone just isn't the guy to listen
to about this stuff
or maybe roger stone does know something
but it's going to be a very interesting
upcoming six months
and um probably the right advice for the
adult trump kids to lawyer up
my guess is they probably have already
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube at
youtube.com forward slash the
davidpakmanshow
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform
at steemit.com davidpakman
that's s-t-double-e mit.com forward
slash
at david pakman okay so we've talked a
lot today about the sort of
general political circumstances of the
u.s the creeping authoritarianism and
some of the other
cultural and political concerns let's
now talk a little bit more about
elections and the the sort of picture
that's forming about not only 2022 but
also
2024 because there really appears to be
a solidifying movement
behind donald trump for 2024. there
appears to be energy behind this
and we've already gone over the report
of trump telling people he'll be
reinstated by august
i've already told you that trump is
restarting the maga rallies as soon as
later this month
and there is now a new report out from
the washington post that donald trump is
increasingly obsessed with these
bogus sort of q and on ballot
audits that are happening in arizona and
potentially in
other places check out these excerpts
from the washington post which writes
quote
advisors say he voraciously watches any
television coverage he can find
of the arizona recount and reads
everything he can get his hands on about
the audits according to one person who
speaks to trump frequently
listen trump doesn't read if trump is
reading anything you know he's obsessed
with it to get trump to read something
really means it's unusual uh the quote
goes on and he has made
supporting his claims of a stolen
election or at least remaining silent
about them
a litmus test of sorts as he decides
whom to endorse for state and federal
contests
in 2022 and 2024. this goes directly
to what we talked about earlier one of
the big three reasons
that so many republicans currently in
power voted against the january 6th
trump riot commission
is they want to stay on donald trump's
good side and this report from the
washington post tells us
trump is paying attention in terms of
who he supports
in 22 and or 24. the washington post
continues quote everyone is talking
about arizona he said to an advisor who
tried to broach
2022 endorsements he brings up the topic
at various events even at non-profit
galas at his private mar-a-lago club
where he has made impromptu appearances
this spring they said
anyone's who tell anyone who tells him
that he lost one adviser said
is pissing into the wind when advisers
write speeches for him that do not refer
to attempts
to re relitigate the 2020 election
trump ad-libs riffing on states in
granular
detail now in addition to this the
associated press
is now reporting that multiple people
who have spoken with donald trump and
his team in recent weeks
say they sense a shift with trump
increasingly acting and
talking as though he does plan to mount
another white house
bid here is trump on the dan bongino
show just a few days ago trump
seeming to hint at running in 2024.
let's take a look
i'd be remiss the audience is dying to
hear it i know you've been asked a
thousand times
forgive me but i have to ask where are
we with 2024
you we we need you man we need you big
time
you thinking about it are you leaning
one way we'd love to hear it well
i'll tell you what we are going to make
you very happy and
we're going to do what's right and we've
done a great job
for the country rebuilt our military and
had the greatest economy ever twice
you know we've rebuilt it then the world
collapsed with
the whole world collapsed with it and
then we built it again with the stock
market was higher than it was even the
first time
okay so every indication right now
is that this 2024 nomination is trump's
for the taking if he wants it
the republican party has shown no
interest in blocking trump in any real
way
uh sure mitt romney would block him if
he could but mitt romney is not the
republican party right now
even though remember trump led to
republicans losing the house in 2018
losing the senate in 2020 and losing the
white house in 2020.
they should be saying this guy is toxic
for us but he's in control right
now there is every indication that most
republicans
are going to fall in line and go with
trump because
they themselves want trump's endorsement
and they need trump's recommendation
and that's going to be a factor in 2022.
now
what could at this point sideline trump
for 2024
uh one thing would be obviously if he
just doesn't want it then he's out but
i'm saying
if trump wants 2024 what could sideline
him
one thing would be that the people he
supports in 2022
lose most of them all of them a bunch of
them that will reduce donald trump's
power
because that would mean that the
trump-led gop
will then have lost the house in 2018
the senate in 2020
the white house in 2020 and at least not
taken control of the house and or senate
in 2022
that would be bad for trump's chances in
2024. so
this is why 22 matters so much if the
trumpian wing
gets crushed next year it has a
potentially big impact on 2024
whoever wins 2024 will be president
until january of 2029
so understand the effect that 2022 has
but they are building this entire
infrastructure with the upcoming rallies
and everything else
and unless something gets in the way
even if it's republicans themselves
getting in the way
trump is sailing towards the nomination
in 2024 if he wants it
now okay the other issue of course would
be a health problem for trump i get a
ton of emails about this
that could happen with anybody i know
people maybe focus on trump more because
he appears so unhealthy and the obesity
and everything else
but you know you the truth is that
anybody when you're talking about a race
that's three four years out that could
affect anybody and this is why
as we mentioned earlier historians are
so worried about the continued march
towards authoritarianism based on the
polling right now
based on trump's continued support from
within the gop electorate right now
it really appears that number one
they've learned nothing from the last
five years
and number two they seem to be totally
unfazed by the creeping authoritarianism
of that trumpian wing
of the republican party i'm increasingly
convinced
that if the party was planning to shift
away from trump
they would have already done it and i
know people will say well you got three
years
if they don't shift away for the start
of 2022 and trump is left in the
position of dictating who's on the good
list and the bad list for republicans
the ship will have sailed and it will be
trump in control
now one thing that is not going well for
donald trump
is his much promoted new social media
communications platform
i call it a blog it's already been shut
down
i guess it lasted about 29 days this is
so embarrassing
months spent promoting what's basically
just a glorified
glorified glorified glorified blog spot
page
on his donald j trump.com site it's gone
the page from the desk of donald j trump
has been scrubbed from the website
and it quote will not be returning
according to donald trump's senior
lackey jason miller
if you try to access the page now it
just redirects you to a sign up for his
mailing list
so what happened here i think it's
really simple it failed miserably
nobody was reading it it was barely
getting any attention
no one cared about it it was doing
nothing positive for donald trump so
it looks bad to have something up that's
not doing well
and so trump took it down and now it's
also possible to put the most positive
possible spin on this
it's possible that because trump is
allegedly restarting his
maga rallies later this month he's just
shifting
to a different means of communication
via email
trump lackey jason miller downplayed
that they were ever making a big deal
out of this he said quote
it was just auxiliary to the broader
efforts we have and are working on
but anyone who remembers the period
between trump's twitter ban
and the launch of the blog knows they
were promoting this thing as if it was
going to be
god's gift to humanity this blog and had
it gone well
they would still be talking about it and
promoting it in that way now
hilariously they are sort of again going
back to promoting something even bigger
this is so funny on twitter amy
tarkanian
the former nevada republican
congresswoman a chairwoman tweeted
the desk of donald j trump section of
trump's website has been removed
and will not be returning perhaps this
is a precursor to him joining
another social media platform to which
jason miller replied
yes actually it is stay tuned
it's all pathetic it's all a failure in
total it lasted about a month and it's
gone and genuinely though
i was never interested in the blog i am
interested in the upcoming rallies
because we've been wondering you know
what's the future of the republican
party what's the mood
of the gop heading into 2022 i think
interviews with rally goers in june july
and august
are going to give us the first real
insight into the mood of the average
trumpist at least to some degree as far
as the blog itself
i actually think it's more likely that
it wasn't
the non-existent web traffic that trump
was so
pissed off at i think trump was mad
that the posts weren't making news for
almost
five years trump would tweet and it
would be news in real time
on all the major cable networks and all
over the place trump
was i mean almost every day there was a
headline based on a trump tweet
and then trump has this blog and it's
just not making any headlines
and um i mean honestly trump
not tweeting for the first few weeks
that he was off twitter
made more news than anything trump ever
published to this blog so it came and
went i guess it's uh
let's see a scaramucci is is is
scaramucci 10 days
how long anthony scaramucci lasted so
29 days would be like about three
scaramucci's worth
and it is gone much to the delight of
many people
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
um here is a caller furious with me that
i said yesterday you know
new nuclear could be a bridge
to sustainable renewable power uh this
this caller is very angry take a listen
david what the hell are you talking
about new nuclear
you sound like donald trump when he
talks about clean coal there's no such
thing
no such thing david they haven't figured
out what to do with the waste
that we make from current nuclear plant
technology
uh metal containers leak after 30 35
years
on the ground leaking liquid radioactive
waste into the soil
and you're talking about new nuclear but
please
quit insulting the audience there's no
such thing as new nuclear
no such thing the bottom line is we've
got to get
out of coal and oil that's what we got
to do
so this is unfortunately a case where um
the end goal we agree on but we disagree
about
the possible role of nuclear listen i'm
not a nuclear activist
i'm not going around saying let's bring
on new nuclear
i'm not doing that i think that we could
given that we can't just get off of oil
right now i think we should just build
up go straight to renewables
but i concede that i would be lying if i
said there was no case to be made for
new nuclear as a bridge
the fears about safety from the 70s do
not apply to new nuclear technology if
we were to use it
used fuel can be recycled in ways we did
not previously know that it could more
than 90 percent of its potential energy
still remains in the fuel
after five years of use in a reactor we
are learning more and more about storage
including dry cask storage there are new
safer nuclear reactors that include
uh sodium cooled fission as well as
advanced
fusion uh the fission technology reduces
nuclear waste and can even use the waste
as fuel so
i'm not saying a nuclear yo let's do it
i'm saying the reflexive anti-nuclear uh
standpoint of some on the left
is based on 40-year-old technology and
understanding
of tech of how nuclear works um
that's it that's all i'm saying so let's
all relax all right let's let's simmer
down
on the bonus show today we are going to
talk about
a number of different things including
this trading frenzy another
meme stock amc stock doubling
we will talk about ron desantis forcing
forcing cruise ships to accept
unvaccinated passengers what
and the state is seeking 30 years
for derrick chauvin for the murder of
george floyd
derek chauvin is asking for time served
in probation
that's a big gap we'll talk about all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show i would
love it if you got access to the bonus
show today
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
the memorial day special code
goes until tomorrow it is memorial 21.
really strong discount alright i'll see
everybody on the bonus show
[Music]
momentarily